では よろしくお願いします
あべこべ感覚で生きるという
まあこういうテーマではね
大体かなり前 喋り話したことで
最近あのリピート講演しようかなと
こちらとあちらでまあ一応やってます
ですから そんなに珍しい内容はないと思います
私は知らないという現状
そのテーマについても
あべこべで 最初は結論というか
最後に言うべきことは最初に言って
最初に言うべきことは最後に言うという
あべこべにして話します
それでもやっぱり序論は序論ですから
序論について あべこべっていうのは誰のことと
世界は自分たちがあべこべだとは思わないんですね
まあ大体人間っていうのは
私の思考はあべこべだよとは誰も思ってないんです
世間の教えと違うことを宗教が語る
それなのに 我々一般社会で言っていることと違うことを宗教が語るんですね
特に日本の社会はそこを激しく区別してやりまして
学校や教育ではね 精神の尊さやらね
心の主義とはもう語ってはならない
禁止だと と思っていて
その上で子供が問題を起こすと
いや 道徳を教えなくちゃって言ったって
道徳は何かとわからないんですね
だからそれはどこかあの
まあ会社で教えていることと同じだと思っているみたいし
だからまあ 世間で笑われるほどのおかしいことは
日本の学校で道徳人権として教えてるんですよね
やっぱり金儲かるだけこそ人生やということはね
はっきり出てますね 他の国ではやっぱり文化がありますから
宗教はガン宣伝するってことはないんですね
アメリカでも一応憲法では政教分離ということなんですけど
誰一人分離しないんです
大統領にしたっても 全て一生懸命
堂々と自分の宗教を宣言して
大統領に委任する先生の時でもしっかりと宗派名号という言葉で司会も加えます
それまた聖書を持ってきて宣誓しますから
何が政教分離だと それは日本ではもう絶対あり得ない
無理 もう厳密にもう なんて言いますか
厳密論者で もう今さえ食っていければいいやということがはっきり出ていますね
それで皆様にとっては分かりやすいと思いますよ
だから 宗教が言うことと
我々は学校で学んでいることってあんまはっきり違うんだと
それで我々は間違ったことを学んでいると誰も思わないでしょうね
学校で教えたことこそ正しいというふうに普通は思っているし
例えばヒンドゥー教も含むすべての宗教は
この世は世そのままで事実として認めないんですね
ヒンドゥー教でこの世こそがマーヤ
幻覚 幻想ですね であり
真理は不二アドヴェーアドバイタというね
だと解く これ唯我一論ということなんですね
じゃあこれ説明します
ヒンドゥー教でこの世の中は幻想
幻覚であると 幻であると
本当の世界っていうのは
この唯我一論というね
魂であると言うんです
それはヒンドゥー教哲学ではかなり有名な考え方で
アドヴェーアドワイタというんですね
不二ということで で そうなってくると
私たちの世の中はありますけど
家族もいるし 人間もいるし
友達もいるし 動植物もいるし
そういう世界なのに ヒンドゥー教ではこんなのは幻覚だよと
あるのはたった一つだけだと
それはもう神の魂そのものしか何もないんだというふうに言っている教えなんですね
うん 他の一神論を語る宗教も
この世は本物で ん？ではなく
ではなく まあちょっと間違えます
本物ではなく 本当の世界は別に神に用意されていると信じていますよ
だから我々普通に聞いている他の一神論と語っている宗教ありますね
で まあ名前で言えばイスラム教やキリスト教やらね
で 彼らが言うのは やっぱりこの世の中は
この世は本物の世じゃないんだと
本当の世界は 我々永遠に生きる世界は
神様は別なところで用意しているんだと
一般人にはこの世は事実です
しかし 我々一般人にとっては
まあそれはどうかなと
わからないし 知らないし
ヒンドゥー教で世の中は幻覚であると言ったっても
もう神の魂そのものであると
と言ったっても ただの普通の人間しか見えませんね
神の魂はなかなか見えないんですね
我も私も神で あなたも神だというようなね
ヒンドゥー教の有名な言葉っていうのはどうも理解わからない
あなたは神であるで なんでこんなこと何もできないただの人間ではないかというふうに思ったりするし
だからキリスト教とか
そういう宗教では まあ本当の世界は別に用意してありますから
この世の中はどうったことはないと言ってますけど
我々にとってはこの世の中は本当のことになっているんですね
ですから 大変な問題が起こらない限り
宗教でいう話にも居場所にもあまり興味がありません
だから世の中の人々は
もう大変なことが起きたら宗教に走りますけど
まあどうにもならん 何かできことを来たら
もうすぐ宗教に行くんです
そうでない限りはまるっきり興味ないんです
宗教で言っているのは変なところでわかりませんよと
そんなことをするよりは
もっと現実を見た方がいいんではないかと
事実を見た方がいいんではないかと思ったりはする
そこで総括でどういう結果になるかというと
倫理と心の安らぎがもう危険な状態になりますね
宗教は世界があべこべだと説く
宗教があべこべだと世界は思う
宗教の世界はもう世界があべこべだと言うし
世界は宗教にあべこべだと思っているんですね
欲を満たしながら長生きすることが正しい生き方だと本心真面目に思っているから
倫理道徳などの価値は優先順の最下になるんです
そこでこれは言っていること本当ですよ
世間に対して世間何言うかというと
やっぱりもう欲を満たしながら長生きすることでしょうと
だから道徳なんかは優先順では一番下
もう出てこないんですね
だからすごい真面目でね
まあ道徳を守ろうとかね
嘘をつかない人間になってやろうではないというと
まあそのうち今は仕事をして
金儲けて やりたいことを全部やって
まあそのうちやりますと
そのうちはなかなか出てこないんですね
自分の期待さえ叶うなら
いかなる残酷なことも惜しまないのは人間の本音です
これも覚えておきましょう
自分の期待さえ叶うならば
どんな残酷なこともするのは人間の本音なんです
だから たまたまどこかで子供が人を殺したんだからって
そんな驚くほどのことじゃないんですよ
普通に よく真面目に仕事をした人が
突然隣の家に強盗に入って人を犯したとか言ったってもね
それは不思議なことじゃないんです
買い物に行ったら 誰かに包丁で刺されたったと
で それで犯人を捕まってみたら
なんだ なんでそんなことその人を知って知らないんだと
全く知らない人を刺しちゃうんでしょ
そうすると なんでそんなにただ刺したかったみたいです
それだけ だから そういうケースというのはいくらでも日本の社会ででもあります
それって不思議だ この世の中どうなっているのかとか
テレビで喋るくらいのことじゃないんです
どうせ道徳否定している人々だから
そんなわかるわけでもないんです
それが普通なんです 人間の本音っていうのは
自分の期待だけ叶うならば
別にそれから考えません
だからテレビ見たり ゲームをやったり
漫画を見たりして もう映画を見たりして
やっぱり刺してみたいなという気持ちが出てくるだけ
人を刺してみたいなと思ったら
包丁を持っていて 誰か刺すんです
それがなんでガチガチ言うのかと
私のことは人を刺して殺してみたかっただけやと言うんですよ
本人は それでその人おかしいというのはおかしいんですよ
その人おかしくないんです
普通です ただ 自分の期待を叶うという
いわゆる普通の世間の生き方なんです
人を刺さなくても 他の人々もやっぱり自分の期待
希望 願望を叶うならば
それこそ生き方だと思って生きているんです
ですから この何でしたっけ？倫理には説得力がないんですよ
とことん儲かりなさい
金持ちになりなさい ライバルに勝ちなさい
成功を収めなさいなどの話は当たり前の事実だと思うが
欲張ってはならない 嘘ついてはならない
敵を許すべきなどの話は信じ難いでしょう
そんなことで何を敵を許す？そんなこととんでもないんだと
我々日本の文化っていうのはとことん恨むことやと
ちょっと何か誰か失敗したら
その人のことを恨むは恨むは
例えば ある家族で人が犯罪でも犯したら
その家族はその地方からもう跡形もなく逃げなくちゃいけないんです
犯罪を犯した人は一人なんですけど
年取った親までおじいさん
おばあさんまで引っ越さなくちゃいけない
あの村で あの町でもう生活できないんです
指を刺されるんです なぜかというと
他の人は何も悪いことをしない
もうみんなもう神様のような人間だからね
それで他の地方に行ったっても
名前まで変えないと すごいいい社会ですよ
だから この 普通は敵を許せなさいという話はわかるわけじゃないんです
敵を倒すべきだと 敵を許したら敵に負けるんじゃないかとかね
言うんです だから私は言いたいのは
そういう批判ではなくて
嘘をつくなよと言っちゃうと
ちょっとわからない なんでやと
しかし とことん嘘でも何でもして金儲かりなさいと
あのカンニングでもして試験合格しなさいと言うと
それはそうだと できれば替え玉でも入れて試験に受かってくださいと言えば
いいことを言うなと できることならやりたいと思っちゃいますよ
だからそこは本音なんですね
だから我々本音でとにかく長生きして
もう欲望を満たして生きることをこそが正しいと
宗教は阿呆なことを言ってるんだと思ってるんだから
そうなっていて 道徳を語っても説得力はない
その言葉こそ阿呆だ思う
だから嘘をつくなよと言うと
なんだ阿呆なこと言うなよと
この世の中で嘘をつかないで生活できるわけないでしょと言うんです
あべこべ争いで倫理 心の安らぎは危ういんですということ
それであべこべのもう争いがあるんですよ
で 世間は宗教に対してはあなた方あべこべなことを言ってるんだ
宗教の人々も世間を見て
あなた方はあべこべなことを言ってる
お互い様もうライバル同士で争ってるんですよ
それでお互いあべこべだということでどうなっているのかというと
誰も道徳的倫理的な生き方はしないんです
だからとにかく自分さえ良ければいいという生き方をしているんだから
世の中は大変危なくて
息苦しくて 心の安らぎじゃない
例えば 私が自分勝手で自分のために生きているんですけど
誰かに殺される可能性はあります
誰かが私の部屋に空き巣に強盗に入る可能性があります
誰かが私の部屋の鍵をね
ピッキングする可能性があります
だから心の安らぎはないんです
で この心の安らぎなく生きているのは
別に部屋の鍵かけなくてもいいでしょうね
窓を開けて空気通るように
今寒いんですけど 今私は出ていたでしょうね
だからその時間だけでも窓を開けて空気がいっぱい通るようにしておけば
もう体にはいいんだけど
それはできないんですよ
だから自分が部屋にいる時
窓を開けなくちゃいけない
それだと寒くて どうにもならないんですね
だから そういう苦しいことになっているのは
やっぱり世の中はまあそういうことになっているだからなんです
道徳はあまりもう気にしないだからなんです
で 例えば窓を開けた窓から泥棒が入ったら警察に訴えるんです
警察は何言うんだ お前が悪いんだと
なんで窓を開けておいたんですか？なんで気をつけないんですか？と言って調べようともしない
もし泥棒が私がやりましたと自首すれば
どんどんとテレビに出て発表して
警察の方々はマスコミに向かって
まあ今日 なんたらなんたら容疑で逮捕いたしましたと
自分で調べて犯人を探すということは
よっぽどのことがない限りはやらないんです